pour la maman
[Musique]
salut salut
j'ai un copain on en est parfaitement
conscient
[Musique]
j'ai pas envie de garder ça pour moi
j'ai pas trouvé le bon moment
ton groupe d'amis est génial comment
est-ce que tu les as rencontrés
[Musique]
ton coming out quand et comment tu le
voudras
[Musique]
Tao je crois que c'est la pire personne
sur qui crochet pourquoi tu sais pas de
flirter avec lui ma mère me supplie de
me faire couper les cheveux tu es mignon
avec les cheveux longs
poire ce rendez-vous je vais perdre ma
meilleure amie pour toujours
[Musique]
je t'aime je disais pas ça pour que tu
répondes que toi aussi
Charlie c'est que tu veux pas faire ton
coming out je veux faire mon coming out
prêt pour notre grand voyage à Paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de tout ce que vous ressentez je ferai
tout ce que je peux pour que Nick n'est
pas affronté ce que j'ai dû affronter je
le protégerai
tout va se passer à merveille
tu crois que les autres vont marquer
oh mais non
je crache sur lui depuis tellement
longtemps il y a des fois où j'ai
l'impression qu'on ressent les mêmes
choses mais et même si tu fais des
erreurs comme tout le monde tu es
quelqu'un de bien et tu mérites d'être
aimé
oh je sens qu'ils vont être intenables
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
n'est pas obligé de comprendre ses
sentiments pour savoir qu'on apprécie
quelqu'un on n'est pas obligé de
toujours maîtriser les choses on peut
juste les ressentir
[Musique]